hey guys this is dennis the founder
think Carol and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of breaking bad
season 5 the final season 14 14 called
Ozymandias yeah this is like the big one
is the big one this is like the the is
the rains of castamere yeah any of you
guys watched Game of Thrones this is
like the red wedding episode right for
Breaking Bad this kind of one of the
most intense episodes for breaking bad
because they built basically the whole
series to lead up to this point because
many things happened in verse you know
we kind of thought maybe before was when
uh Hank found out about Walt but that
was just kind of leading up to this
episode yeah this is everything went
down we've never really had episode
where everything just went crap I mean
everything just went horribly wrong this
is where everything falls apart
everybody knows what's going on now
everybody you know at me even you know
Walt Jr knows what every everybody knows
what's going on that's on the table
right now first of all the this episode
is directed by Brian Johnson you know
the the movie director who directed a
looper Lou bloom brick you know he's
directed a few episodes before but I'm
sure they specifically wanted him for
this is the kind of a unique visual
style and he definitely brought that
yeah cuz it's a very intense episode but
you know instead of starting off at the
end of last episode when the shootout
they started with a flashback right I
think they did that because they wanted
to show kind of like how the
relationships were back then I mean you
saw how Walt when he was gonna call
Skyler and lie to her how like you know
he rehearsed it yeah he's rehearsing
he's like you didn't know what to say
I'm so unused to it you were now like
his lies just come out like just second
nature yeah and his relationship with
Jesse was different and English katoh
they kind of had a decent relationship
then it was kind of a little of their
idea now it's stalled gone to crap but
it a used to have a little bit of love
back then yeah it's different and jesse
was the kind of goofy and like the whole
science stuff I mean now he knows how to
cook we know that but before yeah he
didn't care what any of that yeah yeah
so and then they jump back into the
shootout you know we you know watching
last episode even though they didn't
show
Hank dyeing you knew he was gonna dock
right you knew it because of the way
they set up how he called Marie and you
know all this like Oh congratulations
it's all over I got you bubble perfect
time you know yeah I mean it just I
can't say anything this episode as great
as it was as well done as it was nothing
was shocking no I wasn't like I mean
seeing hanka t kill it's like well
obviously I mean you kind of see you
know its company it's still hard to see
but it wasn't shocking ending which is
but it doesn't take away from how good
the episode no no no this is definitely
one is a great episode of breaking out
bad you know I'd probably have to
rewatch the whole series again you know
to see where it ranks but steadily in
the top right now one of the top three
probably episodes maybe top five right
you know i don't remember exactly other
ones but yeah like Hank's death and they
kind of just matter of fact yeah you
know they did it that's the thing with
you know Todd's uncle and his crew I
mean those guys are ruthless but they're
just real business about it I mean
they're not I mean there's all
conversations in the comments about this
are not good guys Todd's not a good guy
necessarily but I mean they're just they
they're matter-of-fact about like look
like we need to get this guy killed so
we can move on with our business and hey
we'll leave you a cut because Todd
respects you and he's my nephew so I
respect him so when leave you loved
million dollars like it just like so
matter-of-fact about the Duncans it's
like what sounds good to me he's that
good to you like he's not like an unfair
guy he's ruthless he's mean he's cruel
but he's not unfair it's really
interesting it's racist and races yeah
that's an old nochi he is racist but you
know it's like it's interesting to see
that really in Chad Todd a meth demon I
know talk a little mostly like when what
was crying tuck him did like one of you
know one of those yeah I got all sad so
it's really interesting and also I think
we saw the last I don't know a little
bit of Hanks like humanity in a way
because he was uh he was really pleased
willing to trade 80 million dollars for
Hanks life yeah I think that's the last
of it though I think you're right and
then after after Hank was killed I think
that was great that was it I mean I
actually I mean he did try to save his
family are not saved but he wanted to
get away with his family and start
starting new you know he's just
too far it's too far it's too late to do
that to stay over yeah i mean he's
basically paying for all the things that
he had done before because remember he
retired he hasn't been doing anything
really bad but he's been trying to cover
up and all these things and all come to
all right i'll come to a head I don't we
don't get to give him a lot of credit is
because he's not a lot of scenes but
i'll say Walt Jr the actor that he did a
great job you know just the reveal when
Skyler told him everything like his
reactions you know just being like he's
like you're not shooting me are you
stuff like they just like all this stuff
all these lies are you lying now eat
online now what was a lie mean his shock
on his face he did read it early cuz he
adores his dad he all his dad is like
the best even when found out he's like I
want to talk to my dad I won't talk to
my dad where is he like he's still one
to hear the story from him yeah only
until when he saw Walt and Skyler
fighting did he kind of turn on my dad's
I know this isn't right and you know
even lied a little bit insane like that
that Walt had pulled the knife yes he's
Skyler pool not trying to kill somebody
but I did I did like again another just
Brian Johnston great job directing I
love that you know watching that scene
and you know they had the focus on the
phone and the knife or right in the
camera and it's like which one is she
gonna choose and she chooses the knife
and we see it later on in the episode
the scene again and she chooses the
phone yeah definitely some Wayne Johnson
style yeah in this episode we good
directing choices yeah we had talked
about this and speculated about this
before we knew that at some point jesse
was gonna learn about Jane yeah we
didn't know how though we didn't know I
wasn't gonna cold-blooded oh well yeah
like stick it in there yeah cuz he was
he feels betrayed by Jesse and so that's
why he told him cuz we didn't know in
that episode the fly I don't know if you
remember than one where there he and he
was kind of delirious and something
years old he almost told Jess right you
know right it's kind of been a secret
he's been keeping this whole time we
didn't know that he was just gonna
outright just tell him you know yeah I
mean what went bad i mean after the
whole emotional breakdown when hank was
killing me he just went dark him he's
like hey Jesse by the way and we're
gonna get tortured for the next five or
six days by you know these guys by Todd
and his boys but by the way I also let
your girlfriend died I could have saved
her like take that and when they were
about to kill him he was like yeah I
just go ahead like no no yeah obviously
the argument he had with sky
over the phone calling her a [ __ ] and
decide just just I mean like I said I
know people get you know there's
comments i think scott the actress and
the gun wrote an article in The New
Yorker one of the big papers and kind of
defending her character Vince Gilligan's
very apologetic about Skylar she just
never been my favorite character I know
a lot of people say she's were acting
rationally that's in a way she should
react to her situation maybe that's true
I don't think he's always been written
that Walsh is my opinion but um I
actually felt bad for her in that moment
when Walt was just berating her all
those just mean hurtful things at that
moment I was like man I can't feel kind
of bad well because there's only thing
about her her baby Riley yeah which is
like of course you can think what a bit
yeah oh yeah I mean could just be thrown
up into fire trucks you know I yeah I
mean everything I mean you got you know
Walt Jr fangs out of his my dad he's
crushed yeah Maurice crush cousin she
found out Hanks dead right and then
Skyler you know she doesn't know where
baby is but you know if she's never
gonna see her again I mean luckily well
you know realized that the best thing
for the baby is not to be with him and
all new on you know and at least Walt
did that least look baby go that was
smart least let the baby go yeah so now
I guess I mean and then I guess go talk
to about about Jesse little bit now
Jesse's over there with todd todd is I
know you're not supposed to like his
character like as a as a human being
that again because she got a little kid
he's not a good human being but on this
is television this is fake no one's
really dying in these episodes so I mean
it's it's night he's an interesting
character to watch well that's like the
context of people hating on Skyler
versus wall yes Walt is the more evil
care right like in real life scholars
doing the right thing yeah she should be
angry yet but this is television but
people are annoyed at Skyler right
because it's in the context this is
television sure you know we're not
talking about let's talk about Anna Gunn
as she acts in her real life I'm talking
about Skyler what the character I don't
yeah not my favorite character on on
television right now but I've nothing
against Anna Gunn as a person but I want
to say that I do like I'm curious to see
what Todd and Jess you're gonna do I
mean Todd's just again once to impress
Lydia we know that from the last episode
so he's going to try to make the best
batch that he can of course it still
doesn't make any sense your he has 80
million dollars yeah to split it's like
70 so oh it's right that's right he gave
it all right Sony million-dollar so what
the point yeah I I don't know I don't
know why they even bother cooking
anymore I mean we've got plenty of money
I don't I woodley I wouldn't even stick
around though oh I think I'll see you
later and I go enjoy this money I really
like though I thought this is a nice uh
no this is the writing of the directing
a great choices to not show the torque
Jesse's torture oh I like that is cut
cuz episodes so heavy he already killed
hey we saw a lot of deal we don't need
more torture and Morgan I like they just
cut to him after you can tell he's been
tortured for a few days I like they
might have shot the scenes and decided
that it right too much yeah I like also
it's it's it's AMC it's not HBO sure
there are certain things they drew you
know what go too far right but i think
it probably most like it was like what
you were saying who probably a little
too much to see right giving you the
episode right I was gonna look at guess
you know talking about all this I guess
looking ahead I mean so we now know wall
at the end he takes the was it Saul's
will get a jail free card yeah basically
the new identity program right so he's
gonna go off to New Hampshire Vermont
wherever he's going to go so again we're
trying to say what's gonna bring him
back yeah with the machine gun with a
machine gun yeah like who is he trying
to kill is it Jessie because right now
he doesn't have any beef with anybody
but he doesn't know that Todd is keeping
Jesse alive and Walton are saying is
that Todd and his boys are gonna kill
him after they interrogated him so
they're gonna rebuild the Empire again
is gonna be the Todd and Jesse team I
can't I don't know I don't know oh yeah
so I don't know I mean I don't know if
he's coming back to kill you know the
the Nazi Brotherhood by the Misseriya or
just Jesse and yeah I couldn't see him
he's not gonna go aggro on his family as
much as he you know talk [ __ ] about
Skylar the whole time right he's not
gonna go aggro on them right so I mean
that's really the only choices know that
he's gonna go and try and exact some
sort of revenge right Jesse and I wonder
like oh this be bigger than the shootout
we just saw we'll even get to the shoot
I wonder how the Indians I'm sure it's
gonna be great but I can't imagine
what's gonna be like yeah me I assume
one of one of the two are gonna die
señor Walter we're gonna die I did I
don't see both of them dying right one
of them is going to
and but yeah it's an exciting two more
episodes yeah alright guys so that's
what we thought of this pretty
monumental episode Breaking Bad let us
know what you think what did you think
of any everything that happened in this
episode and how the whole series is led
up to all these moments you can post
comments on our YouTube video in the
below section that's a youtube com /
think hero pro make sure you subscribe
to that channel we also have a Twitter a
page that's a twitter com so I think
hero I can also find me on Twitter i'm
at griffin de and we also have a
Facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash think hero fans and you also check
out our website think hero calm
you